so let's get to this morning I was
browsing the David Pakman show reddit
discussion forum more than 4300 of our
viewers and listeners now participating
in respectful political debate there you
can find it at david pakman.com slash
read it a few interesting conversations
that caught my eye there starting with a
conversation about Donald Trump
spreading fake news about Iran this is
very very funny but Donald we didn't
cover this because how much of trumps
Twitter can you cover we're trying to
focus on the most important stuff but
yes Donald Trump did retweet
totally fake very very fake from the
failing fake news media actual fake news
and it was about an Iranian missile
launch and it was pathetic and it was
embarrassing and it was completely
unsurprising because it's what we've
become accustomed to also from our
reddit discussion forum one of our users
J 473 who's been hanging out on the
reddit for a long time said if the
Democrats put up an average candidate in
2020 Trump is going to get trounced and
although I believe it is too early to
talk about 2020 I respectfully disagree
I believe that Donald Trump we've done
the math Donald Trump can win this
election
with 26% of the registered vote in other
words not 26% of the vote but because
voter turnout was only 50% Donald Trump
actually won the election with only
about a quarter of all eligible votes in
the United States and even with the 30
or 32 or 29 percent approval rating
Donald Trump can still win in 2020 so I
don't want this type of confidence
because this is exactly how Donald Trump
will get reelected also from the reddit
discussion forum an interesting piece
from Vox about how 39% of rural
Americans do not have broadband internet
and I actually read a really interesting
article about I guess it's like the
least connected County in terms of
internet in the entire country I believe
that it is in Colorado and you see if
you're looking at this that one of those
internet dead zones appears to be parts
of Colorado really interesting and I now
am completely considering internet
access a utility just it's like
electricity it's like running water and
when you consider that and you
look at the sort of economic
consequences and cultural consequences
of lack of access to Internet really
really scary stuff very good piece by
Vox on that and lastly from the reddit
discussion forum a very important
question for David what is in the cup
you should have the logo on both sides
they're talking about
I believe this coffee cup that is next
to me it does have the logo on both
sides that's the thing it's usually
water but if I am feeling like I need a
boost I'll toss a little nambian cough
EFI into it and that'll really perk me
up for the show sometimes I need that ok
but it's usually water usually water
david pakman.com slash reddit
participate there are moderators you
won't get trolled all of that stuff